the State Department is defending
secretary Rex Tillerson over criticism
from his own employees some officials
are upset about tuitions decision to
leave Afghanistan Iraq and Burma off a
list of countries using child soldiers
all were included in a lineup of 11
countries unanimously blacklisted by
Department bureaus the decision prompted
State Department officials to take the
unusual step of sending an unsigned
dissent memo accusing Tillerson of
violating US law and compromising
American credibility Margaret Brennan is
at the White House Margaret good morning
good morning well the secretary is being
accused of violating US law meant to
stop the use of child soldiers this memo
reveals that Tillerson rejected the
advice of top state Department officials
when he kept three countries off of a
blacklist effectively making it easier
for the u.s. to provide those countries
with military aid under a 2008 law the
u.s. is required to publish a list of
countries whose forces use child
soldiers any country on that blacklist
is barred from receiving weapons or
military aid unless the White House
issues a waiver which has been done in
the past but in this case Tillerson
chose not to use that legal method
yesterday State Department spokesperson
Heather Nauert defended Tillerson
decision saying he reviewed all of the
facts but State Department officials
argue in this dissent memo that
Tillerson disregarded the evidence he
was presented and they raised concern
his omission could weaken us attempts to
stop child trafficking it also lays bare
once again the divide here bianna
between America's diplomats and the
Secretary of State yeah Margaret this is
the first time many Americans are even
hearing about such a law thank you